Welcome back. We have already gone through a bunch of theory about univariate, bivariate
and multivariate analysis and now we have a good idea of how to deal with different
kinds of variables and what sort of inference we can draw from those variables. In this
video we are going to get started with Excel and how we can use all the univariate, bivariate
analysis techniques that we have studied so far within Excel. Specifically in this particular
video we are going to deal with how to do basic arithmetic using Excel and how we can
extend that same idea to come up with better statistics, more complicated insights and
so on. First of all this is a little small so we can just go to the view tab over here
and do a zoom to 100 percent so that our text looks fairly readable. So as you can see this
is the iris data set which you have seen a few times before. As we know we have four
numerical columns in this data set and we have one categorical column in this data set
which is the species of a given flower and every row is basically a sample of the flower
and every value over here is basically the measurement in centimeters of one specific
attribute of that flower. So basically for this particular row what this means is that
the sample length of this particular flower was 5.1 centimeters, the sample width was
3.5 centimeters, the petal length was 1.4 centimeters and the petal width was 0.2 centimeters
and this particularly was a setosa version of the iris. So let's see what we can do with
this sort of data. Let's try and get started with some basic univariate statistics. Before
we start we have to designate the first row of our data as the header. You see Excel yet
doesn't know that this is our header. Now in order to do that we can just go to the
view tab over here and we can click on freeze top row. So when that happens you see that
Excel has frozen the top row which means that no matter how much I scale I can always see
the top row no matter how much I scroll. So what that means is that Excel now knows that
this is the header of my file. Now one of the most important univariate statistics
that we have is the mean or the average. So let's try and calculate the average of the
sample length column. So in order to do that first what I'm going to do is need the sum
of all the values in this column. Now in order to do that we are going to use an Excel formula.
There is a special way to use an Excel formula. You see whenever you are in a particular cell
of Excel you can just start writing anything. So I can type this. This is basically just
me writing text in certain cells of the Excel sheet. But if I want to start writing a formula
I have to begin by pressing the equal to key. So basically this is now going to be interpreted
as my formula. So I can just write something like sum of A to A. What that means is that
take the sum of the entire A column. This is my A column and A to A what it means is
that take the whole column into consideration and then in order to execute that formula
we just press enter. So that's what we know. 805.6 is the sum of this particular column.
Of course if we also knew the exact length of the column, we know that the numerical
values start from row number 2 and go all the way up to row number 139. So I can also
have a specific range instead of the whole column. So for example I can have sum of A2
to A139 and you see that we get exactly the same value. But of course it's not always possible to
know the complete length of the column without scrolling down. So that's why we can just use
E colon A wherever it applies. Now that we know that this is the sum, so let's call it
as sum of simple length. Let's correct the typo. Now the next thing we need in order to find the
mean is basically the count of this particular column and that can easily be obtained by another
formula which is called simply count. Here again I give it an A colon A because again it just
helps me not, saves me the trouble of typing the exact coordinates of where the columns are.
So that's it. I know that I have a 138 rows in my column and then my mean, I can just call this the
count and let's make a little space so that the values and their names are readable. So this is
the sum of the simple length column, this is the count of the simple length column and then the
average of the simple length would be another excel formula which I can just say it's equal to
this value divided by this value. So what I did was I simply wrote an equal to sign and I clicked
on a particular value then I typed in the slash sign which indicates division and I clicked on
the other cell that actually was the divisor and then when I press enter that's it. That's
basically the mean of my particular column. Now let's try and continue this with the other
columns so let's say I want to do the same thing but for the simple width column so I'll just
basically do sum of b to b and then I would just do count of b to b well in this case obviously
it's not going to change. Oh that didn't work you see because I did not precede this with an equal
to sign and that's why excel could not interpret this as a formula so when I do that it gives me
138 and then again I simply say that this is a formula which divides the cell which is g5
divided by the cell which is h5 and then I just press enter and that's the average of the simple
width then again I can do the same with the petal length which is c to c then again I do a count
and made the same mistake again almost c to c and then I just say that this is a formula which is
g6 divided by h6. For the sake of completeness let's also finish this for the petal width column
which is d to d d to d and we have a count of d to d and then we simply have g7 divided by
h7 and there it is those are basically our average values of all the four columns now actually
instead of doing each of these steps manually there is a smarter way to do this let us write
down the names of our columns over here so let me just copy these names and let's say that we
type them down over here and let's say that here I want the sum so basically when I do
a sum of a to a that gives me my sum 805.86 now I don't really have to copy and paste the same
formula or you know everywhere else what I can do simply is drag this so when I drag this particular
formula you see that it automatically scales to figure out the correct formula substitution for
the rest of the columns and you can see when you click on this particular cell you can see the
formula here it's basically a colon a and when you click on this one you see that it's basically
sorry yeah when you change it you can see that it's b to b and then you see it it's c to c
and again sum of d to d so basically we didn't have to manually type down any of these formula
it's basically all of it is straight away present for us so we all you have to do is basically just
take this formula and drag it across so this is basically called a range selection in excel
and excel is smart enough to figure out what are the values over which you're trying to apply a
formula based on how far you're dragging it and what is the original what is the original
formula so it's pretty smart like that now let's say that I have all my sums ready in this particular
column then I can just do a count column or in this particular row that is then I can do a
count row which I can simply say as count of a to a and there it is and again as usual I just drag
this so basically it gives me the count for all columns and if you look at the formula at the top
left over here it's count of a to a then it's count of b to b then it's count of c to c and then
it's count of d to d and then finally when I come to the mean here I can basically just say this is
equal to this particular value divided by this particular value and that's it that's my mean
this also is draggable so when I do that it basically drags to give me the same values as here
so you see this is basically h12 divided by h13 this is i12 divided by i13 and this is j12 divided
by j13 so basically these are my means and I can very easily calculate them just by filling in one
formula and then expanding it to fill all the columns of interest now note that this is just
an example of how you can use excel to do basic arithmetic which is basically sum and division
multiplication and subtraction also works in a very similar way
and we are going to see examples of that very soon however we didn't even have to calculate the mean
manually by summing and dividing there is already a formula for v
as you might have guessed it's excel after all you can just say average
there it is and you can just drag this over as we know already and you see that we get
the direct values exactly so let's just call this the direct average right so that's our average
essentially let's continue and try to compute the variance also this time so as we know the variance
is basically you take the average of a particular column you subtract each value from the column
that average and then you square that value and take the average of that value so essentially
what this does is that I am basically going to take the sum of a particular column which is say
a to a or in this case I will give the explicit range which is a is to a 138 then I have to
basically sorry this should be a 138 and then I have to subtract essentially the mean and we know
that the mean is this I have to then square it so basically that carrot symbol means exponentiation
and then I square it to the second power and then finally I divide it by the count which is 138 so
that gives me the variance of the sepal length column and again I can just drag this to include
the variances for all the other columns and of course this was a variance that we calculated
by actually applying this particular formula let's take a look at the formula a little more
carefully we took a column we subtracted the mean of that column which was present here
and then we squared the column added it up and then divided it by the count of that particular
column so that's basically what gives us our mean sorry our variance obviously there is also a
direct formula for variance there are actually two formulas one is called a population variance
versus a sample variance so in this case we are talking about a sample variance so in this case
we can just do a to a and there it is it produces a sample variance of 0.69 looks like we were a
little off but that's because we might have considered the value the formula that we considered
could have been the formula for the population variance instead of the sample variance so let's
try and change this and see if we can actually replicate the same thing with the population
variance and yeah that's a much closer value and again I can just scale this up and that gives me
the variances the directly computed variances of all columns the last thing that we need to consider
is say the standard deviation so let's just call it std and that would just be the square root of
this which we have known since the previous video so we can just say another formula for
taking the square root which is sqrt and then you just click the value for which you want to
take the square root or essentially fill in its cell number and then you finish that so that's
basically the standard deviation as usual I can just drag that and there it is however as usual
as you might have expected so far there is also something called the standard deviation
a direct standard deviation so I can do something like std ev again since it was a population
variation we can population variance we can use the variance the standard deviation value
which corresponds to the population so that would simply mean a to a and that gives us
pretty much the same value and as you extend it there we are so that basically gives us most of
the univariate matrix which we can apply on continuous or numerical columns
so these are all the statistical mathematical movements and the
metrics that we can derive from our data we had also discussed some graphical ways of deriving
univariate analysis specifically for numerical columns those are histograms so let's see how we
can draw histograms well it's fairly simple in excel you just select a column and then you go
to the insert tab and say that you want to insert a chart so this is the area where you are going
to find all your charts now the chart that we are looking at is a statistical chart but let's also
take a look at what excel recommends so this is a button for recommended charts and you see that
it's basically going to give us bunch of scatter plots it's going to give us histograms it's going
to give us Pareto distributions so obviously we want histograms so let's click on histograms
and there it is that's basically the histogram of sepal length let's just move it a little
outside so that we can still see everything that's already there so there it is i can also click on
this particular button here to change you know the color of it so basically it's blue and let's say
i want it in green so i can click on this it becomes green and i can edit the chart title
i can say that this is basically the histogram of sepal length and there it is that's basically
how i can quickly draw histogram using excel if i want to do it for another column again i do the
same thing i go to the i select the column i go to the insert tab i look at either the recommended
charts and if the histogram doesn't show up in the recommended charts i simply go to the button
which corresponds to the statistical charts which is this one and i click there and i see that there
is an option here for a histogram and that essentially gives me my histogram for the petal
width column as well and again i can use a bunch of different styles with these charts so as you
see we can change the color but here we can also change the whole style so let's say i want something
like this with a black background and a slightly matte kind of a finish then this is what my chart
looks like remember that you can just choose any sort of a slide or style that you want and you can
use any sort of a color that you want you can also size these accordingly you can edit the markers
and the titles as and when you like so that is how you can get histograms out of excel
so that takes care of all the univariate analysis that we can do on continuous variables but we
haven't exactly thought of what we can do with categorical variables that is for example something
like the species column so let's see what we can do with them let's move this entire section of
work out of here so that we can basically make some room for our analysis for the categorical data
now as we know the only thing we can do with categorical data in this case is count it
it doesn't support any other operations now in order to count how many different values are present
and how frequently they occur the first thing i need to do is figure out what are the unique
values that are actually present in that so for example let's say i have this column e which is
the species column and i want to figure out how many different species are there
if i do a quick scroll i see that setto size there there's versicolor and there is also virginica
in some parts of the data set however i want to programmatically using excel find out which are
the unique values so what i can do then is go to the data tab and i can say that i want to do an
advanced filter when i click on the advanced filter you'll get this warning but that's okay
you'll see that you get this window which will let you specify what sort of a filtering you want
so let's say that i want don't want to filter the list in place but i want to copy the output to
some other location so basically let's do that and we say that the range is this and i only want
unique records and i want to copy to say a particular file which is say f115 and when i
click on okay that's what i get i get species setosa versicolor and virginica so now i have
the unique species ready under this particular column so i have species here and let's also
create something called a count so now i just want to count how many setosas are there how many
versiculars are there and how many virginicas are there simple way to do that is to use another
formula called the count if formula so basically what count if does is it counts values in a given
selection that is a range so let's say my range is basically the entire column which is e to e and
the criteria is basically what you want to match it with and the criteria i want to be setosa what
this means is that the criteria is setosa so what i mean by this is that count the whole column e to
e if any value matches setosa and then i can just press enter and so it tells me that it has 46
columns similarly i can just do a copy and paste it over the new columns and it gives me 46 so
basically here i'm saying that count all the values in species such that they are versicolor
count all the values in species such that they are virginica so that's how i get my count values
now one quick way to basically convert this also into a graphic is to select this data let's say
that these are my unique species and these are their counts of course in this particular case
it's a balanced data set so all species are equally probable and equally present and then
again i can go to insert and i can insert yet another chart so i can say that i want to create
a pie chart and there it is that's our chart we have setosa versicolor and virginica all occupying
exactly 33 percent of the pie chart and that's how we can simply do a counting of
the frequencies within a particular categorical column